اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي فجر
اليوم محيط مخيم بلاطه في نابلس واجرت
عمليات استفزازيه في محيط المخيم ثم
انسحبت باتجاه حاجز بيت فوريك شرق المدينه
في عمليه استفزازيه هي الثالثه من نوعها
في غضون
اسبوعين معنا من نابلس مراسل الجزيره ليث
جعار للاضاءه اكثر على الاقتحامات
والاعتقالات المتواصله في الضف غربيه ليك
ليس نعم يعني ساع في ساعات ما بعد منتصف
الليل في مدينه نابلس نفذ الاحتلال عمليه
عسكريه ووصلت عشرات الاليات العسكريه
وقدرت هذه الاليات بما يزيد عن 25 اليه
الى محيط مخيم بلاطه والى المدخل الرئيسي
للمخيم ومن ثم عاود الاحتلال الانسحاب
مجددا فور وصول هذه الاليات باتجاه حاجز
بيت فوريك الى الشرق من المدينه بعد ذلك
اعاد الاحتلال الاقتحام
مجددا برفقه جرافه حتى وصلت الى اطراف
مخيم بلاطه ثم عاودت الانسحاب مجددا وهي
للمره الثالثه خلال اسبوعين فقط في عمليه
استفزازيه واضحه من قبل الاحتلال لسكان
مخيم بلاطه هنا حيث نتواج في هذه الاثناء
ايضا حاجز دير شرف الى الغرب من المدينه
حيث لا يزال الاحتلال يعرقل حركه
المواطنين يقوم بالتدقيق في هويات الماره
في كل يوم وفي كل ساعه وفي كل لحظه هنا
على الحاجز حيث يعاني الفلسطينيين من
التنقل ما بين م المدن الفلسطينيه تحديدا
في شمال الضفه الغربيه المحتله هذا الحاجز
يربط مدينه نابلس ب مدينه طولك كرم بمدينه
جنين
واهنا عند حاجز دير شرف يغلق الاحتلال
الحاجز باستمرار ويقوم بعرق حركه
المواطنين في هذه اللحظات الحاجز يبدو
يعني اخف ضراوه مما كان في السابق وفي
خلال الايام والساعات السابقه حيث يعرقل
الاحتلال باستمرار حركه المواطنين ميدانيا
ما جرى الليله في الضفه الغربيه من حمله
مداه مات
واعتقالات نفذها الاحتلال في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله حيث اقتحم ايضا مناطق
شمال مدينه طولكرم منفذه حمله مداهمات
واعتقالات لعدد من الفلسطينيين في بلده
قفين الى الشمال من المدينه ايضا في رام
الله كان هناك اقتحام لقريه دير ابو مشعل
الى شمال الغرب مدينه رام الله ونفذ
الاحتلال خلالها حمله اعتق قالات طالت على
الاقل 20 فلسطينيا تم نقلهم الى مراكز
التحقيق في منطقه البيره ايضا خلال ساعات
الليل نفذ
الاحتلال حمله مداهمات واقتحام لمنطقه
البيره اعتلى اسطح بعض المنازل وسط
مواجهات لكن سرعان ما انتهت وانسحب
الاحتلال من المنطقه في ضواحي القدس ايضا
كان هناك اقتحام لمخيم قلنديا وج مواجهات
على اثر ذلك ادى
لاصابه فلسطيني ومن ثم وصل تم نقل هذه
الاصابه الى المستشفى وايضا على صعيد
مدينه اريحه كان هناك اقتحام ايضا للمدينه
من المدخل الشمالي وتم اعتقال طفل من مخيم
عين السلطان ليث جعار مراسل الجزيره كنت
معنا من نابلس شكرا جزيلا لك